[Music]
all right let's go to jordan in san
antonio texas hey jordan how are you
i'm all right how are y'all doing good
what's going on
um it's pretty hard to call it a new
path for help but um
what is your message for
what is your message for people who
like in my situation
um we screwed up we were davish and just
got ourselves in more trouble
and uh
i'm back on track personally i'm doing
spu again i've got i paid for it i'm
watching the videos online but and i'm
doing my budget we're we're sticking to
it right now but it's so
disheartening
yes
um
and again it's just
there's a lot of pride just even ask for
help yeah um but what is the pickle my
situation
well jordan first of all
i want you to have some grace for
yourself
we all screw up
i've screwed up
georgia screwed up
dave ramsey has screwed up he built this
company that now is this big success
that everybody looks at
on a screw-up
on going broke bankrupt
he talks about remembering crying in the
shower with a baby on the way
feeling exactly like you feel right now
so i just want you to know
we all screw up
and there's grace for you
we all do it
tell me a little bit more about your
financial situation though so george and
i can give you more specific advice when
you say you made some mistakes what are
we looking at here in terms of debt i
know you're back into financial peace
university and you're ready to turn it
around and you need help and i hear you
and we want to help you but can you tell
me a little bit more about about the the
details of your financial situation
um well
we're about seventy six thousand dollars
in debt
we have after budgeting about sixteen
hundred dollars to throw at debt so i
mean it's pretty good numbers when we're
being disciplined um
the other part that's playing on this is
that
um
two years ago when i first started fpu
and when i was davish whatever i ended
up losing my job and sold the house
before i could lose that and i've lived
in a two-car garage next to my parents
since then it floods every time it rains
i mean i battle ants every day i've got
like three different columns of ants
trying to get in right now
and it's taking a toll on my wife and
not his marriage but
i mean it's just the the cheapest way we
can live so that way we can you know put
money towards any form of debt
i mean with the cheapest apartment we
found around here is like 857 which you
know
was 1600 i guess it's okay but still
that's
when we start talking about paying for
trash and electric i just don't think
it's really doable
um does your wife work
yes ma'am she makes forty one thousand a
year
today
what's your total household income
um as of today basically 120 000.
okay
jordan listen to me
i want to tell you what i think is going
on
from my standpoint
you make hundred and twenty thousand
dollars
that's a great income
you have seventy six thousand dollars in
debt you had some debt but you can get
out of this
you can get out of this sooner than you
think what is absolutely
wearing on your soul right now is where
you're living in these freaking ants
and the floods it's killing your spirit
get out
get an apartment you can afford an
apartment the four walls we tell you to
take care of before any debt one of them
is you're living your your home your
housing
that is a priority before any of your
payments and i appreciate your
dedication and i know you feel
sad and shame from making a mistake or
being davish but you have gone so far
that you are sacrificing your physical
living situation your marriage is at
risk your mental health is is is
struggling because of this what's
killing your spirit is actually not your
finances your finances are in a position
to get yourself right on out of this you
have a great income
it's the ants
it's where you're living george am i
missing something here i mean i feel
like this like
i i think she's spot on and jordan let
me ask you this uh let's say you get out
and you're paying rent that's going to
change some things for you guys
emotionally right yes you're going to
have some mojo back and go oh my gosh
yes we don't have to deal with the ant
problem i can go take on a side job and
not come back to this two-car musty
garage that we're living in and what
kind of debt is this
um
so there's two credit card debts that
were used to start a business that
failed um
and there's hospital debt
okay and there's a card debt okay so uh
is the car worth selling do you know
what the car is worth versus what you
owe on it
uh well we just bought it several months
back well in april so it's about 40 000
plus right now if i would sell it it'd
probably still be
maybe 30 grand if they give me anything
for it i mean if i'm you i'm getting rid
of this car and even if you're
underwater uh i would take out a loan
from the credit union or from a bank
that's the only time we tell you to do
that is when you're underwater on that
vehicle but man that's gonna give you
some some uh spirit back and actually
make you feel like you can get this
stuff done it's gonna make a huge dent
in the debt yeah that's half the debt
right there and then the medical debt
try to negotiate that down advocate for
yourself fight for this see if they'll
take less uh and try to settle on that
for way less than that once you start
doing these things you're gonna go oh my
gosh i can see some light at the end of
the tunnel and it's not an oncoming
train
jordan listen you're going to sell this
car
you're going to get an apartment you're
going to be in an awesome apartment
you're going to be in a better situation
from a housing standpoint you make 120
000 a year and you're going to almost
cut your debt in half if you do what
we've just told you to do that is going
to lift your spirit which is going to
give you the momentum to tackle the rest
of it you have got this
you are in a better position than you
realize you just need to take hold of it
you got this